bientôt sur disney channel les bikers
contre certaines des surfeurs
c'est vrai que ça sent le poisson avarié
des rongeurs je savais bien qu'on aurait
dû apporter des pièges à rats vrillé
faire la planche et vous laisser
emporter par le courant
ça va faire mal
tous les surfeurs sont méchants peut-on
pas que si méchant découvre petit matin
dallaire il est là ces 4 6 6 races de la
cnac qui gueulent match et bras du
différend j'aime bien ça va me sortir
avec une fille parce qu'avec la moto
lamari refuserait d'emporter une fille
parce qu'elle fait de la moto la vérité
c'est que les motards ne sont pas si
méchants sous ses dehors de beau gosse
tu es intelligent oui mais plus beau
grâce à mitsui c'est ton nouveau disney
channel original movie
or et c'est bientôt sur disney channel